today on the matt walsh show after a
summer of rioting spurred on by a
handful of high-profile police shootings
today i want to
take a look at what we can actually
learn from those cases they seem to
provide a blueprint
for how to avoid getting killed or
maimed by the police
and it's not as hard as you might think
also five headlines including uh a man
peacefully protesting by defecating on
nancy pelosi's
driveway it's not funny we will condemn
it in no uncertain terms because it's
not funny at all
and in our daily cancellation i will uh
cancel joe biden for claiming that
you'll die
in a hurricane if trump is reelected all
of that on the way but two
uh two notes just to start right at the
top first if you watch this podcast on
youtube you should know
on september 28th it will be moving from
the daily wire channel to be available
exclusively on my youtube channel
youtube.com matt walsh you can get the
link in the description below
i'm also making a lot of new content
that you can only find on my channel so
subscribe to you to uh to my youtube
channel
youtube.comwalls very easy to find ring
the bell to make sure you never miss out
on a new video go do that
now well after this go do it um second i
want to tell you about lifelock you know
the truth is in life
you can't trust anyone well you can't
trust a few people maybe friends and
family hopefully you can trust but on
the internet on the internet you can't
trust anyone
there are there are bad actors on the
internet a lot of them
can't even trust your own grandmother on
the internet especially if she died
already and she's contacting you that's
that's a big red flag
the fbi cyber division is warning that
students and families will be
increasingly vulnerable to cyber attacks
because of uh the current online
learning and all of the teleconference
and everything all of these different
applications
uh since the start of the pandemic
there's been a 300 percent increase in
cyber crime activity hackers are
becoming more sophisticated and taking
advantage
of teleconference accounts through which
they are pawning information like emails
and passwords
you gotta talk to your kids about
protecting their information kids are
stupid they do dumb things let's be
honest
you've got to be able to protect them
also it's important to understand
you know how cyber crime and identity
theft are
affecting our lives every day we put our
information
at risk on the internet and cyber
criminals
they keep finding new ways to steal
identities and you could miss
certain identity threats if you're just
monitoring your credit
uh you know if you're taking basic steps
like that which is good to do
but you need lifelock life like lifelock
detects a wide range of identity threats
like your social security number being
for sale in the dark web
if they detect your information they're
going to send you an alert
and uh listen nobody can prevent all
identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses but
you can find out if your information is
on the dark web
get your free dark web scan at
lifelock.com
scan pick the plan that's right for you
save up to 25
off your first year with promo code
walsh okay that's a free scan
lifelock.com scan 25
off but you got to use promo code walsh
all right well our summer of rioting
has been of course ostensibly fueled by
several specific incidents in which
black suspects died or were severely
injured during an
attempted arrest by police blm and its
allies have selected these cases and
singled them out
as a representative of a larger systemic
problem
and we're told that the men who were who
were
killed or or injured george george floyd
rachard brooks
jacob blake deon k daniel prude ricardo
munoz
most recent one these were victims of
police brutality
and they were targeted because of the
color of their skin
but if we examine all of the cases
together now that we have this sample
size
and we compare them objectively we don't
actually find any evidence of racism nor
any apparent connection to systemic
problems in law enforcement
what we do find is that all of the high
profile quote unquote victims
over the last several months made
similar choices
and that their choices not their skin
color can be directly linked to their
deaths
see their cases provide for those who
need it a reverse
blueprint for how to avoid getting
killed by police
simply do the opposite of what floyd
brooks and company did and
your chance of surviving an encounter
with police is very near 100
regardless of your race so let's review
briefly okay george floyd
violent felon high on potentially lethal
doses of fentanyl
tried to use counterfeit money resisted
arrest died of cardiac arrest while
being restrained by police ray shard
brooks
lengthy arrest record passed out drunk
behind the wheel of the car uh resisted
arrest assaulted police
stole officer's weapon attempted to use
it against them
shot and killed by police jacob blake
credibly accused rapist and and serial
abuser
uh allegedly harassing his alleged rape
victim
resisted arrest assaulted police pulled
a knife reached into a car
shot and injured by police deon k known
gang member
flashing guns and live streaming on
social media fled from police then ran
towards them with his gun drawn
shot and killed by police daniel proved
37 previous arrests
high on pcp running naked through the
street had spit
a spit hood placed on his head because
he was spitting at officers after
claiming to have had
covid died several days later from
complications of asphyxia according to
the
uh coroner report ricardo munoz most
recently previously charged with
stabbing four people in 2019
he was trying to break into his mother's
house charged at a police officer while
wheeling a large knife looked like a
butcher's knife
shot and killed by police okay
there are a number of obvious
commonalities here every man on this
list
was a known or alleged criminal
they were all allegedly in the process
of committing a crime
three were under the influence of some
sort of intoxicant
three were in the process of trying to
assault or kill police officers
three were armed um at least five of the
six were resisting or evading arrest
it's claimed that prude was not
resisting but he was delirious and
spitting
whether or not that counts as resisting
is up for interpretation i suppose
none of these men were just walking
innocently down the street or sitting on
a park bench somewhere minding their own
business
none can be called law abiding in none
of these cases
is there any apparent or uh
apparent connection to or evidence of
racism or racial profiling
in all of these cases police were called
to the scene because the actions because
of the actions taken
by the suspects which had raised varying
degrees of
perfectly justified alarm among the
public
these cases far from proving that there
is an epidemic of police
killing or brutalizing innocent people
actually provide very strong evidence
for the opposite conclusion
there is no such epidemic in fact it
would appear that a person has to make a
series of very bad choices in order to
run any significant risk of a violent
encounter with police
as i've previously demonstrated a wider
view of the issue
leads to the same conclusion take 2019
throughout all of 2019 police arrested
around 10 million suspects 70
were white um uh
30 were black a total of 14 of the 3
million black people arrested
and and or rather killed during an
arrest were unarmed only six of those
cases really count as unarmed when you
read the details remember again this is
out of three million arrests
only one titania jefferson was an
entirely innocent person minding her own
business
gunned down by police randomly while
sitting in her house
there's nothing she could have done
different obviously fortunately the
police officer
has been charged with murder there was a
similar case in 2018 when
botham jean was was killed by an
off-duty cop while he was sitting in his
own apartment
that officer went to prison this year
there was briana taylor
though in that case she was killed in
the crossfire when her boyfriend
fired on police during a no-knock no
knock raid it's not exactly the same
as the jefferson and jean cases but even
if you want to
put it in the same category we're
looking at about what one
instance every year out of millions and
millions of police
arrests and interactions in the vast
majority of police shootings
they are responding to lethal aggression
from the suspect it would seem that
the six high profile cases from this
summer are pretty accurate
representations of the larger trend
actually
uh blm and their allies certainly seem
to think so which is why they're rioting
based on those cases so
then what can we learn from them how
might a person
who wants to avoid getting shot and or
killed by police
choose to behave what could all of these
men have done differently
a blueprint emerges if you want to give
yourself like a 99.99999
or even larger probably chance of not
dying at the hands of police
all you need to do is one avoid
committing crimes
two if you're going to commit them avoid
doing them while high on lethal doses of
narcotics
three avoid assaulting police four
avoid pulling weapons on police five
avoid resisting arrest
now it's safe to say that if if almost
everyone that
you know almost everyone in modern
american history
who has followed these five steps has
not died at the hands of police
they all have or will die of something
else but police
won't be the cause if you follow these
steps
the list of things that is more likely
to kill you regardless of race is
extremely lengthy
and includes things like lightning
strikes bear attacks meteors
this isn't to say that everyone who
fails to follow steps one two and five
deserves to be killed by cops i mean
even those who fail to follow three and
four avoid assaulting police avoid
pulling weapons on police
they don't necessarily deserve it
because deserve is not a relevant word
here
the police officer who shot ricardo
munez wasn't trying to give munoz
what he deserves he was simply trying to
neutralize an imminent threat to his own
life
so this isn't about deserve but it is
about consequences
actions have consequences a very likely
consequence of pulling a weapon on a
police officer is that you get shot
getting shot by a cop is not a
statistically likely consequence of
committing a crime in the first place
i mean most people commit crimes don't
get shot but your chances of that
happening are now
as a consequence higher than they would
have been had you committed no crime at
all
with each bad choice the consequences
pile up
and the likelihood of a disastrous
outcome is heightened
so when you go through steps one through
one through five there
if if if you do the opposite rather than
avoiding the committing
committing the crime you commit it
rather than avoiding uh you know
resisting arrest you resist arrest
as you do as you make each of those
mistakes as
i should say as you make each of those
choices um
the likelihood of a disastrous
cataclysmic outcome a fatal outcome for
yourself
is heightened if you're just you're just
adding to the list as you go down
you do none of those things if you
actually follow the steps you avoid
doing all of that
almost certainly for everyone in america
almost certainly 99.9999
if not more your chances are
you'll be fine you won't be killed by
the cops now even if you think
that there's an epidemic of racist
police out hunting and murdering people
which there isn't
but even if you think that's the case
this should still be your message
this isn't a blm this isn't their
message they don't want to talk about
this
but if you actually value people's lives
and you want to save
lives then this should still be your
message where you should still be saying
listen
if you're if you're getting arrested
resisting arrest
fighting the cop whether or not cops are
a bunch of racist murderers
even if they are racist murderers even
more don't don't fight them
but one way or another regardless
nothing good can come of that for you
at all there's there are zero good
outcomes for you
period best case scenario
you survive the encounter but you just
are going to go to jail for longer now
because you assaulted a police officer
worst case scenario you die in between
scenario your
jacob blake paralyzed in a hospital and
he's still probably going to go to jail
as well he should if he committed the
horrible crimes he's accused of
committing
so this should be the anyone who really
cares about lives
black lives white lives any lives this
would be the message
follow these steps and
police and no harm will come to you from
police
almost certainly let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
you know time is money as they say and
if you're waiting around at an auto
parts store
or you're going to mechanic or something
waiting for your car to be fixed uh
you're not
being responsible with your time i mean
that's that's time that you could be
using
forget about responsibility it's you
could be just enjoying yourself nobody
wants to be waiting around
at an auto parts store so go to
rockauto.com so much easier than walking
into a store
having a bunch of questions i got to
look it up online you got access to
rockauto.com
at your desk you got it in your pocket
so just go rockauto.com you know they
always got the lowest prices available
uh rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear rockauto.com
family business they've been doing this
for a long time serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years you can go
to rockauto.com
you can shop for auto and body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers best of
all prices at rockauto.com are reliably
low
and they're the same whether you're a
professional do-it-yourselfer
why spend up to twice as much for the
same person why spend twice as much
for the same parts if you can find them
you're really spending twice as much for
a
for a smaller selection you go to the
auto parts store the rockauto.com
catalog is unique
easy to navigate extremely extensive
everything you could possibly want
amazing selection reliably low prices go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck write
walsh in there how did you hear about us
box
so that they know that's we sent you
okay andrew gillum
a one-time up-and-coming democratic star
who was then found passed out high on
meth
with a male prostitute in a hotel room
which come to think of it really
probably won't hurt his stock at all in
democratic party but um
anyway he has big news to share in a
brave moment uh he uh he came out as
bisexual watch
to be very honest with you when you
didn't ask the question
um you put it out there is whether or
not i identify as gay and the answer is
i don't identify as gay but i do
identify as bisexual
and that is something that i have never
shared publicly
before well okay i'm sure his wife and
children will be
okay now very proud i'm sure once they
hear that they'll understand
you know i have to say admittedly i'm
not
much of a gay rights activist
just to be totally honest uh it's it's
probably not what anyone would label me
but if i was a gay rights activist
i'd be pretty tired of seeing guys like
gillum spacey come out of the closet as
a way to excuse their scumbag behavior
i i don't think i like that very much
but that's uh gillum's strategy
will it pay off uh will it work it's the
democrat party
in the year 2020 so i'm gonna guess yes
number two you heard about you heard you
heard uh about the uh
what happened after those two la
deputies were shot in the assassination
attempt
and uh then the blmmers showed up at the
hospital and were chanting i hope they
die
not just that in fact they showed up at
the hospital they were also on the scene
as we played the video yesterday there
were some people on the scene
who saw it happen and as the police
officers were bleeding in the street
they were laughing and cheering
uh just absolute soulless
scumbags one activist at least wasn't
having any of that and here he is at the
hospital yesterday watch damn the
shooting of both deputies
in the strongest terms
the activists who were here protesting
outside the emergency room saying
and chanting we hope they die we hope
they die we hope they die
we're here to say we hope they live we
hope they live
we hope they live because those
activists they don't represent
our community our movement our struggle
for justice
they represent the worst in humanity
they are an embarrassment
and they should be ashamed of themselves
because at the end of the day
we're all human beings you know the
amazing thing is the democrat party
um has to choose
between that guy and his message
and essentially yeah and and the blm
activists who are at the hospital
chanting i hope he dies like that they
they prob
both are democrat constituencies so they
have to choose which which which
of those groups are they going to try to
satisfy
and pander to and they chose the i hope
you die
group that's that's who they're going
with not that guy the guy you just heard
there there's a decent man
i'll probably disagree with him
politically but there's a decent human
being
they said no we don't we're not
interested in him he's as far as as far
as democrats are concerned these days
just by saying that
by simply standing up and saying i don't
want police officers police officers to
die
that's radical right-wing rhetoric at
this point and you think i'm
exaggerating but i'm not
that's really how they see it uh number
three
here's an important report from the
daily wire says
a youtuber live streamed himself
defecating
on the driveway of house speaker nancy
pelosi as a peaceful protest
in the footage taken on saturday the man
who identifies himself as armando or
mondo is seen walking the streets of san
francisco in search of the democrats
house
once there he sets up a camera across
the street and walks to her driveway
salutes his viewers drops his pants and
then drops something else
um the 28 year old said he's part of a
niche youtube community that creates
irl or in real life live stream videos
chronicling long stretches of
unfiltered daily life and uh and so this
is what he decided to do in his
unfiltered daily life
but it was i just look we have to
condemn
that sort of behavior unequivocally i i
do not
endorse people going to nancy pelosi's
house
and defecating on her driveway i just
want to stay that i do not find it
funny at all um then again it is san
francisco
and that's that's just you're fitting in
with the local culture
in a lot of ways when you do that number
four
the new york post reports um the macy's
day parade
is cancelled let me pull this up says
the chronovirus has killed macy's day in
the macy's thanksgiving day parade
through manhattan this year instead the
famous retail store
will stage a televised only event by the
way the chronovirus didn't kill the
macy's day parade
bill de blasio did there's there's no
reason why you can't have the parade
just because of coronavirus especially
when you we've had
blm protests and riots in the city you
know for months now
uh but as instead the famous retail
store will stage a televised only event
in herald square
filming over two days um the number of
participants including performers and
workers is being cut to around 25
percent
there there will still be the event's
famous massive balloons
although watching their popular
inflation on the upper west side is a
no-go this year
okay so there's not going to be any live
event
uh there's not going to be a crowd
there will be balloons so what are the
balloons gonna do so they're they're
just gonna
would come on to like skype or something
and say oh here's our balloon
check it out nice balloon huh um let's
see is there actually gonna be a pr is
it will it be a parade
down the street that nobody is there to
see
just a lonely parade with a few people
walking down and empty
it look like a parade during the zombie
apocalypse no one under
18 will be allowed to participate nor
will there be any performances by high
school and college marching bands
only locally based professional marching
and musical ensembles will perform
to no audience this sounds
appropriately depressing number five fox
news reports that reese's
will soon release um something you can
see right here
big cups with potato chips
they will be reese's peanut butter cups
stuffed with potato chips
an abomination an offense to god
this is the kind of thing that people
would people would get would get
smote in in the old testament for this
kind of thing smotin smited
of course if god was going to pick up
the old smiting stick today
i'd prefer if he started somewhere else
if he was going to start smiting but
eventually we'd have to get to this
because this is uh really an abomination
but let's also be honest that reese's
cups are overrated in general so there's
not any big loss here
um it's fake peanut butter
and they're generally probably the most
overrated candy
this only will will just uh make it
worse we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation but before we do
as part of our daily wire audience there
are a number of ways to take in the
podcast
you may listen on apple podcast spotify
another podcast app
you may also watch our podcast on
youtube facebook over at dailywire.com
bottom line
we're making our content available to
you anywhere you watch or listen
and now we're introducing a new upgraded
experience daily wire is now on apple tv
and roku so
members can enjoy all of the visual
elements on this podcast on your big
screen
either live or on demand you could find
the daily wire on apple tv or roku and
download today
you have to be an insider member to
watch live so head on over to
dailywire.com
walsh you can use code watch at checkout
to get 15
off your membership that's slash walsh
code
watch this deal won't last long so act
fast if you want live shows on your big
screen plus
the one of a kind highly coveted leftist
tears tumbler again that's
dailywire.comwalls to get 15 off code
watch and download the daily wire on
your apple tv and roku
today let's get to our daily
cancellation okay today we're going to
cancel joe biden
oddly enough i think this might be old
joe's first cancellation i could be
wrong
and he certainly earned it he enters the
cancelled list
with a bang listen to this
donald trump climate denial
may not have caused these fires and
record floods
and record hurricanes but if he gets a
second term
these hellish events will continue to
become more common
more devastating and more deadly
meanwhile donald trump warns that
integration is threatening our suburbs
it's ridiculous but you know what is
actually threatening our suburbs
wildfires are burning the suburbs in the
west
floods are wiping out suburban
neighborhoods in the midwest
hurricanes are imperiling suburban life
along our coast
if we have four more years of trump's
climate denial
how many suburbs will be burned in
wildfires
how many suburban neighborhoods will
have been flooded out
how many suburbs will have been blown
away
in superstorms
if you give a climate arsonist four more
years in the white house
why would anyone be surprised if we have
more america ablaze
if you give a climate denier four more
years in the white house
why would anyone be surprised when more
of america is under water
we need a president who respects science
who understands
that the damage from climate change is
already here
unless we take urgent action
we'll soon be more catastrophic okay so
much to cover here i don't know where to
begin first of all
his sound modulation is way off he goes
from whispering to shouting
then whispering again randomly he's like
climate change is a huge problem
donald trump isn't doing anywhere
anything anything to address it
meanwhile hurricanes are ravaging the
country and wildfires are destroying our
homes
um it's it's very disconcerting and i
guess it's supposed to be
second point what if we really got here
climate arsonist and climate denier
i have no idea what climate arsonist
means i really don't
trump is setting the climate on fire how
would a person do what is he a volcano
and climate denier is at least a more
familiar label but it's it's no less
stupid climate denier
who is denying the climate we all agree
the climate exists
i don't think anyone is walking around
saying climate yeah right
never heard of it you're talking about
climate we all agree there's a climate
in fact
we all believe there's a climate and
it's changing so there's no climate
deniers there's no climate change
deniers
the question is just what things are
causing the change
and to what degree those things are
causing it that's
that's really the only thing we're
talking about third
biden claims he's not accusing trump of
causing hurricanes and wildfires but
then he proceeds to do
exactly that in fact he directly blames
trump for the weather
he says that if we have four more years
of trump there will be more storms and
fires than there otherwise would have
been
now even if you accept the idea that
humans are contributing to climate
change to some extent
the idea that the effect is that drastic
and that immediate
is preposterous the idea that you could
trace a hurricane directly back to the
individual action
of a particular person on earth
currently is
it well superstitious is what it is
that's the best word for it
if biden really believes this which he
doesn't but many of his constituents
do but if biden really believes it or
whoever believes it
um this this is primitive and
superstitious
on the level of you know ancient people
who thought that
tornadoes are caused by witches farting
or whatever they believed
um we are a couple years away from these
people sacrificing goats
on altars made of human skulls to try to
stop earthquakes
human civilization is going full circle
right back into ancient paganism
we cannot emphasize strongly enough just
how crazy this is
we're used to hearing the left sort of
vaguely blame conservatives for the
weather but
this is worse than that this is blaming
a particular politician
for having personally caused the weather
or for at least having failed to stop it
this this is no crazier than if i was
planning to have a cookout
and um i walked outside of my house with
you and it was raining
and i turned to you and said you bastard
you know i was gonna have a cookout
today
and you go what dude i didn't i didn't
it's the rain i didn't cause well you
didn't stop it either did you
now where is this lunacy coming from
well it's obviously political it's
fear-mongering
for all the grief that trump gets for
fear-mongering what you just heard there
from biden
is i think possibly the most hysterical
and insane fear-mongering
we've ever heard from a mainstream
presidential candidate i think it might
take the cake i i don't think there
could be a more extreme example he he
sounded like a preacher warning about
the end times except that he was just
talking about what would happen if his
opponent is in office for another few
years
so it's political of course but i think
also to the extent again that these
people
actually believe this stuff part of it
comes from fear
and i don't mean just fear that we're
all gonna drown when the ice caps melt
i mean the special sort of terror that
comes from a recognition of just how
vast and powerful cosmic forces are
and how puny and impotent and vulnerable
we are in the face of them
so it's kind of reassuring in a certain
way to think that we can
actually do something about hurricanes
to think that we can put in place some
kind of five step plan
follow you know steps one two three four
five and we'll achieve a whatever
arbitrary percentage decrease in
hurricane ferocity
um that's reassuring it makes us feel
less helpless less at the mercy of
nature but
of course no matter what we tell
ourselves we are still at nature's mercy
whether we like it or not
our weather and climate is largely
driven by that 860 000 mile wide
10 000 degree two octillion ton ball of
hellfire hanging out
in the sky up there um she is ultimately
to blame for the hurricanes
and for every other weather pattern so
you got a problem with it you could take
it up with her not donald trump
i know they're both orange but uh
sorry i had to do it i had to throw the
orange thing in there you can cancel me
for that as well but
joe biden for honestly i i know it's
saying a lot but it's
that's one of the craziest things what
you just heard there really is one of
the craziest things i think we have ever
heard from a presidential candidate
period so he's got to be canceled for
that
and what makes it all the more
disturbing is that although it's one of
the craziest things
um it's not so bad to have presidential
candidates saying crazy things right
but it can it it could even be enjoyable
it sort of keeps things
fun and interesting and entertaining at
least what makes it not so entertaining
and a lot more terrifying is that over
half the country doesn't even recognize
that
as crazy they hear that and they nod
along like yeah you know what
donald trump does cause the weather he's
right
so biden is canceled they're all
canceled everyone's canceled
we'll leave it there for today have a
great day everybody godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
president trump gets nominated for the
nobel peace prize not once but twice
even a democratic governor admits that
the president is doing a good job
and meanwhile the left broadly
encourages
more riots check it out on the michael
knowles show